In my previous video, I talked about what quantum
computing is and what makes it special. But as
a developer, I'm sure you want to know how to
actually write a piece of code that would run
on a common computer. But before we dive into
that, let's just do a little bit of a quick
recap. Instead of the classical bits of 0s and 1s,
quantum computers use qubits. A qubit can be a 0,
a 1, or any linear combination of the two.
And that is what we called a superposition.
We can also entangle multiple qubits. So their
states become strongly correlated.  In order
to change the states of qubits, we apply
a series of gates, similar to the classical
logic gates. And in the end, we want to measure
these qubits so we can get the results.
So how do we take all these concepts into
code? And the answer is simple. We use a
quantum software development kit. In
this video, we will be using Qiskit.
Which is the most widely used quantum SDK today.
Qiskit is based on Python, which is fairly simple
to learn, even if you've never used it before.
So let's write a simple program in his Qiskit.In this program, we will use two qubits.
We will put one into superposition,entangle it with the other, and then
do a measurement of both of them. And
of course, all that is done using gates.
So let's start by importing quantum circuit from
Qiskit. We then can create a quantum circuit
with two quantum registers
and two classical registers.
The quantum registers are used for quantum
computation. One for each qubit. And the classical
registers are used to store the measured results.
We need a classical registers because
even though the physical world is quantum,
the majority of the classical
world is still classical.
And the classical registers allow us to bring
quantum information back into the classical world.
So the next thing we want to do is
apply some gates. And in this program,
we're going to apply two gates. The
first one is the Hadamard gate
on qubit 0. The Hadamard gate puts
the qubit into a superposition between 0
and 1. That means it now has an equal
chance of being measured a 0 or 1.
The next gate we need is the control
not gate,  or "cx" for short.
The control not gate is a conditional two qubits gate. It has a control qubit
and the target qubit.
Without superposition, the control
not gate is fairly simple to understand.
That is, it is as if the state of the control qubit is
1, then you flip the state of the target qubit.
And that's why it's called control not.
And because the states of least two
qubits are now strongly correlated,
we now say they are entangled. So the
last thing we want to do is actually do
measurements so we can get the outputs. And we
do this by calling the measure all function.
And there you have it. We just wrote a simple
quantum program using Qiskit. Now, if you take
this program and run it a bunch of times on an
ideal quantum computer, you'll find out that
there's a 50% chance of the outputs being 00 and
50% chance of it being 11. But you would never
be a 01 or 10. The 50/50 of the first
qubit comes from the superposition. And while
we didn't explicitly change the state of the
second qubit, it got changed anyway because
it is entangled with the first qubit.
So it changes with the first qubit.
So in this program, we created a quantum
circuit which operates at the same level
as classical assembly language and allows you
to efficiently manipulate the qubits directly.
However, if you're not fond of
playing with low level circuits,
Qiskit also offers a number of higher
level algorithms. For example, Qiskit has
a package focusing on machine learning that has
a number of pre-built classes. You can take a
quantum kernel class, use it to train and test
data. You can then take this trained quantum
kernel and pass it into a classical algorithm
such as the support vector classification
from scikit-learn. Then you can then
accelerate your classical application.
Thanks for watching. If you have any questions,
please leave them in the comments below.
Also, please remember to Like this
video and Subscribe to our channel
so we can continue to bring you
content that matters to you.